now he told you about the Border what's
going on there there is something
different going on as well migrants
trying to get in here but right now
they're being followed by Cartel members
armed with long guns and sometimes
they're they're literally next to each
other imagine dealing with that
Lieutenant Chris Oliveira has seen that
for himself the Texas Department of
Public Safety I was dealing with this on
a daily basis kind enough to join us
um Chris you have the video and the
images to prove it and at first I
thought these were like some of those
UFO films that that can't be right but
yeah they are what what did you see
uh absolutely that's why it's very
important to expose what's happening on
the borders not just in terms of mass
migration between the ports of India but
it's a criminal activity that's taking
place with the Mexican drug cartels and
criminal organizations that continue to
profit and exploit the fact that we have
an open border and what you're seeing
right there in those photos it's very
rare to see actual Smugglers that are
bringing illegal immigrants across the
border between the ports of Entry armed
with a rifle we've had several events
early this year but we actually arrested
actually work with the Mexican
authorities to arrest Smugglers that
were armed with handguns but to see a
rifle really shows the capability how
Brazen these these criminals are that
they try to avoid any means whatsoever
to avoid law enforcement so they can
bring either groups of illegal
immigrants across or drugs or whatever
the case may be but that's why it's very
important to have a law enforcement
Presence at the border to have
infrastructure so you can prevent uh
situations like you're seeing right now
on those photos but this is a clear
reality of the situation on the border
right now and it continues to get much
worse as an Congress continue to
increase the more people that want to
come across the border the more the
criminal organizations are going to
exploit that
you know Chris would seemed different
this time with some of the video that
you shot and your men and women shot is
we've always suspected cartels were up
part of this process of getting migrants
across the border and uh you know making
sure that happens but they were out of
sight here they're proudly Insight I
don't know proudly is the right word but
they're not hiding uh from being in
sight and that almost shows a new level
of boldness doesn't it
absolutely Neil I mean we've we've
experienced you know as I mentioned some
of these events that have taken place
throughout the Southwest border of Texas
where you have armed individuals that
actually stand across the river and
they'll taunt either our officers or
border patrol agents or National Guard
even shoot up them we've had cases like
that and now they're actually bringing
people across the river actually arming
themselves really goes to show you
they've really taken it to another level
of brazenness of showing how bold they
are that they really don't care as far
as what's going to happen because they
know right now that they are in control
and that's what we're trying to do as
far as the state agencies trying to show
that we are the ones that are in control
we're going to prevent what's happening
on the border try to go after these
criminals and arrest them but of course
again it all falls back to you know when
you have when you don't have border
policies in place to stop what's
happening between the ports of Entry
this is the clear result of what's going
to happen you're going to see criminal
activity coming across the border
um let me get your quick thought on how
bad it is getting because to hear the
administration telling some of the
numbers back them up that they're down
substantially over the last couple of
months but they don't tell the whole
story namely what you have been picking
up on here so what do you expect in in
these next few weeks in August and into
the fall
well the numbers have been increasing
you know and also it all goes back to
when the federal government started to
use the CBP one app it was all just to
really divert the attention from seeing
these Mass groups of people that were
coming between the ports of Entry to
avoid the media attention now to release
and mass release people at the ports
eventually but we're still experiencing
an influx of people that are coming
across the border between the ports of
Entry uh the past two days you know
nearly 6 000 daily encounters throughout
the Southwest border so we're pretty
much on track where we were you know
pre-title 42 so nothing really hasn't
changed we still have we still have
human smuggling we have criminal
activity taking place drugs coming
across the border as you saw right there
criminals that are armed that are
bringing illegal immigrants across
unaccompanied children so the situation
has not changed the numbers still
continue to increase and we anticipate
they're going to continue to increase in
the coming months as well so that's why
it's always important to have some type
of presence there consequences to
prevent what we're seeing right now and
with that Neil the more people you have
coming across that dangerous River the
more loss of life you're going to have
when it's affecting these migrants that
want to make it across that river that
are being exploited being assaulted
being robbed by these these Smugglers so
it's it's a very it's a very dire
situation right now and that's why it's
so important that we're out there trying
to do as much as we can as a state
agency trying to prevent what's
happening between the ports of Entry
well what you do is remarkable and I
know you never like to take a bow and
you always compliment your men and women
but man I cannot imagine a tougher job
these days what you guys are keeping up
with Lieutenant Chris out of ours always
good to see you my friend hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else